actuellement une personne célibataire
touche un peu plus de 7000 $ en sécurité
de la vieillesse
un copain peu plus de 14 mille 700
dollars une personne seule peut toucher
près de onze mille dollars lancé en
supplément de revenu garanti plus de 13
mille 200 $ pour un couple
s'ajoute ensuite le crédit de tps le
crédit solidarité le montant pour aînés
pour les personnes de 70 ans et plus
total de 20 mille dollars pour une
personne célibataire de plus de 30 mille
300 $ pour un couple
on va plus loin sur l'aide annoncée
aujourd'hui avec le guide book est le
titulaire de la chaire en fiscalité et
en finances publiques de l'université de
sherbrooke le godbout bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillion
c'est une aide qui était très attendu
d'abord au niveau de la sécurité de la
vieillesse et du supplément de revenu
garanti qu'est-ce qui change
fondamentalement pour les années
aujourd'hui effectivement ces tunnels
qui était très attendu alors les années
boye ans se considère un peu laissés
pour compte
voyant les milliards qui apparaissait la
pcu à la subvention salariale lui
trouver qui avait pas beaucoup de choses
alors aujourd'hui 300 $ un montant
unique pour tous les bénéficiaires de la
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse et
200 $ de plus aussi un montant unique
pour tous les bénéficiaires du
supplément de revenu garanti alors un
ennemi qui reçoit les deux ne peuvent
recevoir jusqu'à 500 $ de montanes
sionnel et dans les deux cas c'est non
imposables alors contrairement aussi à
la prestation canadienne d'urgence
qu'est ce qu'on constate t il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir de tests de pertes de
revenus ou de perte d'emploi pour avoir
ces sommes-là le simple fait d'être des
bénéficiaires des programmes nous
qualifie d'emblée jusqu'à maintenant ça
ces deux programmes qui sont bonifiés
aujourd'hui de façon unique mais jusqu'à
maintenant il ya d'autres soutiens qui
avait été annoncé pour les années
notamment le crédit spécial de tps ou
toutes affaires cessantes un cumul de
choses des années avait déjà eu droit au
montant unique de bonification du crédit
de tps et il y avait également eu droit
pour ceux qui ont des faire des ponts
enregistré de revenu de retraite y avait
également eu droit de réduire leur
minimum de retrait de 25% donc des
choses qui s'accumulent au fil des
annonces depuis le
l'animal a alors justement allons voir
l'accumulation de ce qui a été annoncé
jusqu'à maintenant avec les
bonifications
donc on reprend les mesures en question
donc on dit tantôt une personne
célibataire peut toucher jusqu'à 20000
dollars en sécurité de la vieillesse en
supplément de revenu garanti et en
différents crédits un couple plus de
trois mille trente mille 300 dollars et
la bella on oui oui ces savants l'aco
vide et donc on ajoute les mesures
maintenant depuis le début de la crise
est là lorsqu'on ajoute pour un
célibataire
les mesures annoncées donc là on parle
tout à deux d'un aîné qui a pas d'autres
revenus de donc c'est vraiment les aînés
des à plus faible revenu
on rajoute un crédit de tps de prix de
450 dollars on un montant unique de
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse de
300 dollars et comme il ladro supplément
de revenu garanti on lui ajoute
également 1 200 $ de supplément de
revenu garanti
on parle de près de 1000 $ pour une
personne seule déjoue ce qui représente
près de 5% de son de son revenu
disponible en termes de majoration ne
donc c'est quand même significatif et
pour un couple
le 30 1300 dollars initial des
prestations publiques et majorées de
près de 1600 dollars
et encore une fois en termes de revenus
on parle d'une majoration le dans son
code 5 points 2 % de revenus disponibles
ont augmenté pour ses aînés da don c'est
quand même pour des gens faibles revenus
une augmentation qui est qui et qui est
non négligeable c'est non négligeable
mais c'est unique en legault de boussès
est pas un c'est pas un ajout permanent
qui est annoncée aujourd'hui
non c'est pas un ajout permanent mais et
non plus et pallier avez vous subi une
perte de revenus dans le cas de la coved
alors il ya des gens qui n'ont pas subi
de pertes de revenus qui voit quand même
leur revenu disponible a augmenté
cela dit on te tue des nouvelles
dépenses dans le cas de la commune
n'ayant pas eu contrairement à d'autres
de pertes de revenus et ils ont droit
quand même assez à ses prestations look
sont effectivement unique et non
d'imposants et ça ne touche pas que les
plus faibles revenus ou quelqu'un qui
fait
beaucoup plus d'argent qu'ils étaient la
retraite qu'est la sécurité de la
vieillesse a le droit ou suppléments
annoncés aujourd'hui il n'y a pas le
droit au supplément ans dans le contexte
du supplément de revenu garanti le droit
unification je veux dire à la
bonification pour le montant à pour la
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse et
là je sens quelques mots la pension de
sécurité de la vieillesse c'est un
programme qui est quasi universel on est
tous les aînés est pratiquement y ont
droit
mes pensées 79000 de revenus annuels la
prestation est réduite progressivement
jusqu'à 128 mille dollars
donc ce n'est que les aînés qui ont un
revenu au dessus de sa m 8000 $ qui
n'auront pas de pension de sécurité de
vieillesse tous les autres y ont droit
mais là on se retrouve dans une
situation la passion de sécurité de la
vieillesse est imposable
on se retrouve dans une situation où des
aînés au dessus de 79 ils sont trop
riches pour avoir la pleine pension de
sécurité de la vieillesse mais assez
pauvre pour avoir droit la bonification
300 dollars dont imposable mais quand
même situation un peu paradoxale dans ce
contexte là de d'élaboration de
politiques publiques dans le cas de la
cabine
mais on l'a su si justement dans le
communiqué c'était écrit clairement on
l'a ceci à un paiement spécial kobe 19
toutes avaient bon très bien est ce qu
on a d'autres choses à ajouter pour les
aînés probablement que les 7 ce n'est la
satisfaction ne sera pas là alors est ce
qui va rester à voir c'est qu'est ce qui
peut être fait et qu'est ce qui peut
être fait mais la question est toujours
dans le cas de la coved on cherche à
suppléer une perte de revenus et dans le
cas des aînés ceux à faible revenu y ont
pas eu de perte de revenu les aînés à
revenus plus élevés ils n'ont pas eu de
perte de revenus des fois directe des
fois ils doivent avoir eu des
soubresauts dans leurs placements et
d'essai dans ce colloque y ait certains
voudraient d'autres bonifications mais
là c'est extrêmement difficile de
compenser des pertes de revenus
boursiers
parce que aussitôt qu'on en parle la
bourse reprend de la vigueur donc ici on
lui a posé nue faudrait le faire à la
femme de population ça ne s'est jamais
fait je veux pas casser des espoirs dans
ce sens nul mais ça seul et j'aime effet
compenser des pertes boursières en
termes de presstek en compensation peu
de
par les tonnes mouais très bien merci
beaucoup le godbout pour ses
explications ce soir y'a pas de quoi
revoir voir